[Music]
it is Friday you know what that means
notable quotables I managed to get him
with one hand on the gun and they're not
grab it from him not threw it over the
countertop as a gruesome scene is really
bad out there I couldn't believe what
I've seen man oh man everybody how these
people on the streets kidding one by one
to be and in that dugout where there's
still the marks the bullet holes there
we are vindicated we are validated we
are not shutting up and we're not going
away I'm gonna be on another network
tomorrow that thinks I should be in jail
thank you for your patience and your
good questions thank you was facts for
facts and fiction is fiction and a lie
doesn't become truth just because it
appears in the front page of the
newspaper it's pretty historic - sending
Secretary of State to the floor without
a positive recommendation I have changed
my mind on the essence in the White
House they're calling the Candyman I
said to dr. Jackson what do you need it
for I said what do you need this for but
I said what do you need it for I said to
him what do you need it for
I like in my life but we do have a very
special I have known Kanye a little bit
and I get along with Cuddy we are both
dragon energy I'm telling you
caffeine drink watch out dragon energy